[Music]
it was a lovely experience working on
this film and I've and it's just a darn
good movie and I'm very pleased to see
it and I'm pleased that all of you are
here and are still enjoying it I had
come out from Arkansas a few years
before hoping to be in movies and so on
and I had done I had worked in some
television I worked in 6-day westerns
first so I had a good break in with fast
work then when I got the contract at
Universal I got I was in a movie called
bright victory and then they had an
option for a contract and they picked it
up and then it was wonderful because I
had a home base I got so I knew
everybody in wardrobe and makeup and and
so on and hair and I was a good swimmer
not not like my not like Ginger Stanley
and you know my my doubles and all that
but but I was a good swimmer just a
regular swimmer and so I felt very
comfortable doing that and of course the
the underwater scenes were we're not me
but most of them and they were wonderful
swimmers ginger Stanley I was very
grateful and I always went to see the
dailies and I would said oh they were so
wonderful you know people who were
swimming underwater and I wished I were
I could do it I wish I'd been there but
but it was not to be it was well
directed by Jack Arnold and good actors
in the picture thank you I like the
movie too I really enjoy it and I think
for those reasons and plus it plus it
has the scary element into it so I think
for those reasons it it has survived all
these years and and when when it's
screened again it has an audience people
like to come and see it again